certain things spring to mind when you
think about prison barbed wire tiny jail
cells bars everywhere
well not in norway this is hauled in
prison and it's the second largest
maximum-security prison in norway and it
looks more like a resort than anything
else but a 20 percent Norway's
recidivism rate is the lowest in
scandinavia and one of the lowest in the
world
this is how Norway changed how we think
about incarceration while Norway's
two-year recidivism rate is the lowest
in the world Americas is one of the
highest a 2014 study found 67 percent of
American prisoners released in 30 states
were rehearsed it for a crime within
three years and seventy-five percent
were rehearsed it with in five years
while it's tough to make direct
comparisons Norway is doing something
right when it comes to incarceration and
it may come down to a fundamental
difference in philosophy of what a
prison should be Norway banned capital
punishment in 1905 eighty years later
they did away with life sentences and in
2007 a shift in thought a focus on
restorative justice emphasizing
rehabilitation and normality over
punishment what that means is when a
prisoner is sentenced in Norway the only
thing they lose is their freedom which
is symbolized by these large prison
walls
[Music]
norway has two of what's been called the
most humane prisons in the world one of
them is hauled in prison where prisoners
can garden learn to cook and tend to
animals they can also take vocational
classes and prepare themselves for the
outside world after they're released
Alden holds 250 one of its worst
criminals which includes rapists
murderers and pedophiles in America
these criminals would be punished
severely kept in a small cell for most
of the day with minimal time outdoors
with all of their rights stripped the
phrase don't do the crime if you can't
do the time applies here retribution
must be swift and sure for those who
decide to make a career of preying on
the innocent
America's decades-long war on crime has
resulted in one hundred fifty nine
thousand people currently serving life
prison sentences but in Norway almost
all prisoners are released the maximum
sentence is 21 years at the end of this
term five-year increments can be added
indefinitely if it's assessed that the
prisoner has not been rehabilitated even
the worst offenders like Anders Breivik
who murdered 77 people in one of the
worst massacres in history is currently
serving a 21 year sentence
Norway also supports prisoners after
they're released they're provided
housing employment health care and
addiction treatment all of this does not
come cheap hauled in prison spends more
than 93 thousand dollars per inmate per
year compared with just 31 thousand
dollars on average for prisoners in the
United States but Norway incarcerates
far fewer of their population as of 2014
does point oh eight percent of Norway's
population was behind bars that's 75 per
100,000 people in the u.s. it's seven
hundred seven for every 100,000 people
or 0.7%
and if the United States had the same
rate of incarceration as Norway it could
spend as much as Norway does per inmate
and still save more than forty five
billion dollars a year that's the budget
for the entire Department of Homeland
Security no matter how many numbers are
crunched on comparing recidivism rates
or thoughts on punishment versus
rehabilitation it comes down to how
society views its prisoners Nelson
Mandela said it is said that no one
truly knows a nation until one has been
inside its jails a nation should not be
judged by how it treats its highest
citizens but by its lowest ones if
that's the case Norway should definitely
be applauded for its humanity
you